to the Czech Republic now where six
people have been shot dead at a hospital
the shooting happened in the
northeastern city of Ostrava at the
University Hospital the gunman
reportedly shot people at close range as
they were sitting awaiting on the trauma
ward Czech Prime Minister Anja babish
has described the incident as an immense
tragedy for the latest on the story we
can speak to Tom McEnroe he's a reporter
for radio Prague in the Czech capital hi
Tom we understand there's been some
developments on the shooter what can you
tell us about the shooter exactly so we
know that he was a construction
technician he shot six people and to be
operated on as we speak he escaped the
shooting in a car that was involved in a
chase with the police for quite a long
time but eventually he stopped and shot
himself in the head it seems that he's
in dead and what we know is that he
believed he was sick he went to the
hospital repeatedly but wasn't treated
and he was a silent shooter we just know
that he suddenly opened fire aiming at
the heads and chests of people around a
dramatic incident there what our
checketh hora t saying about what
happened so the Health Minister has
called a crisis team and he and the
Prime Minister are both on their way to
the event the president has offered his
condolences and is currently talking to
the interior minister everyone is
shocked politicians are expressing their
condolences of Twitter but of course the
information is rolling it on as we speak
so that there's more information to come
there's also been some opinion that
people who should carry more weapons on
them that attic got there the head of
the security council of the Chamber of
Deputies
actually set up to the shooting that if
people had carried guns in the hospital
then this could have prevented the event
Tom what what can you tell us about
where this happened the city of Ostrava
so the suitable Strava is low
in the far north east of the country it
is a former coal mining city and this
shooting took place at the Truman to
logical emergency department of the
Faculty Hospital of Ostrava and Rapid
Action police were sent in pretty soon
after the shooting happened I believe
that 724 and yeah the shooter escaped
quite soon afterwards in time you know
you said there's a discussion now
already taking place about the use of
weapons I mean how rare is an incident
like this in the Czech Republic
it is very rare this is the second most
tragic shooting in the country's history
the most tragic quality took place four
years back where eight people were shot
the shooter shot himself it's in the end
as well in a restaurant but it's very
rare to have shootings like this we know
that there are about 300,000 licensed
gun owners in the country a lot of them
are hunters and we know that generally
people are against I don't know if you
know but there's a new directive which
is a bit harder to own firearms so
people like to have guns but shootings
are extremely rare all right Tom McEnroe
a reporter for radio Prague with us
thank you thanks